What's Wrong mr. Chumley there's a
difference between chilling and moping
immediately I just kind of feel like
this is a bit of a mistake I would like
to see my dad but not in this current
situation I just want in his eyes to be
normal I don't want to be this weird
fashion model or queer this or whatever
I just want to be his normal kid I
wanted to talk to you because your
energy is just a little off well you
know I always try to conserve energy
before a shoot I know but are you
worried that your dad's gonna come
Haymitch where's the last time you
started out
maybe two years ago so you were already
representing female all right like how
you look now or how was it it was just
kind of covering up no I mean he knows
but you know just not really cuz I've
spoken to him sounds like a really nice
dad here's my thing with Brendan
she just faced her dad she'd realized
that her fears are all in her head
don't worry I'm sure he'll be cool it's
just a weird subject that we never
really talk about I feel like I'm not
really ready letting him into my full
life the worst-case scenario would be he
would feel probably disappointed you
know like he didn't really do a good job
as a parent so this is where we're
shooting at today that's Kate oh that's
the photographer this is wrong it's
friend's dad Hey look at me everyone I
got me a little dressed up for this huh
hardly even recognize you you probably
say the same
yeah but take a seat sure yeah catch up
what's going on
how much have you been good get here I
still plan for the new game wizards
coming out with no watch it's pretty
good it's coming out and open beta this
week
fun times fun times so
I feel stupid it's really embarrassing
and awkward this isn't what I normally
do in my free time or how I normally
ever look in my free time this is what
my career is I mean not to get personal
but did you ever notice anything
different about run as a child just you
know like pertaining to what you know
trans issue or no no I didn't really
feel anything so after kind of moved out
alright so how do you feel if you look
at her now